live to Downing Street here as the
health secretary Matt hankering a virus
and the work that we're doing as a
government to tackle it I wanted briefly
to update you about the Prime Minister's
condition it's great news that the Prime
Minister has been discharged from
hospital and is now continuing his
recovery at Chequers I hope everyone has
seen his message of love and thanks to
all those who've supported his recovery
and to the NHS colleagues who've cared
for him so brilliantly
it's an Thomas's Hospital I know that
they have cared for him as they would
care for anybody in this country and
it's one of the things that makes me so
proud that the NHS is there for us all
and can give its very best to every
single person and has been able to
throughout this crisis I know that all
of his thoughts are with those affected
by this illness and of course the
government is working constantly through
our coronavirus action plan and the aim
is to protect life and to protect the
NHS both by slowing the spread of the
virus to flatten the curve and by
ensuring that the NHS is always there
for you and always has more than enough
capacity to meet the demands that are
placed on it today marks a somber day in
the impact of this disease as we join
the list of countries who have seen more
than 10,000 deaths related to
coronavirus the fact that over 10,000
people have now lost their lives to this
invisible killer demonstrates just how
serious coronavirus is and why the
national effort that everyone is engaged
in is so important according to the most
recent figures 282 thousand three
hundred and seventy four people have now
been tested for coronavirus eighty four
thousand two hundred and seventy nine
have tested
across Great Britain the number of
people admitted to hospital with
coronavirus symptoms is now nineteen
thousand nine hundred and forty five and
of those who've contracted the virus 10
thousand six hundred and twelve have
tragically died our sincere condolences
are with all of them with their families
their friends their grief is our grief
and their stories will not be forgotten
on Friday I said that staying at home
this Easter weekend would be a major
test of the nation's resolve and I'm
pleased to say that the nation is rising
to this challenge I know that for some
people this has been extra tough if
you're at home with their children if
you can't visit relatives because
they're shielding if you're unable to go
to church on this most important day for
Christians your steadfast commitment to
following the social distancing rules is
making a difference thank you for the
part that you are playing in helping to
protect lives at this critical time in
our nation's history but we cannot be
complacent not when there's so much at
stake so please keep going stay home
protect the NHS and save lives today I
want to provide an update on the work
we're doing to slow the spread of the
virus and to build capacity the latest
figures show that in Great Britain we
have 2,295 spare critical care beds up a
hundred and fifty from yesterday so
throughout this crisis with all the
challenges that we've been dealing with
all the operational difficulties and all
of the logistics we have always been
able to provide the very best of care to
everybody who needs it through the NHS
at the start of this crisis people said
that the NHS would be overwhelmed and
we've seen that
and we've seen the risk of that
elsewhere but not here and that is
because of the action that a huge number
of people have taken the incredible work
of so many there is more spare capacity
now for critical care than the walls
when coronavirus first hit our shores
and this is before the nightingale
hospital's come on stream London's
opened and we're already in the process
of building six more around England this
critical expansion is partly because we
have a record number of ventilators nine
thousand seven hundred and seventy five
and partly because we have record
numbers of returners coming back and
rejoining the NHS over five thousand
former staff are now back on the NHS
front line and over 36,000 have come
forward to enlist and this bolstered
capacity has been backed by substantial
financial support as the Chancellor said
whatever our NHS and vital public
services need during this time they will
have but of course there's always more
that must be done so we're increasing
the amount of PPE and I'm glad to say
that there are now record amounts in the
system and we need the right amounts of
Medicine - and I can assure everyone
that we're working very closely with the
pharmaceutical supply chain and hospital
pharmacies so that the right medicines
are there to treat people and I'm glad
to see the reassurances that have been
provided today that everybody can have
the medicines they need in order to get
the care that they need